laptops
water
devastation
[Music]
now if you were the owner of one of
these you'd probably first cry
and then you'd immediately go to the
apple store and that's exactly what
apple wants you to do the company and
many others restricts how and where you
can repair your stuff in a variety of
ways
apple says this is to make sure
customers receive safe and reliable
repair services
but now some elected officials and
lawmakers want to give you more choices
with what's generally called the right
to repair
this doesn't mean you have to go all
rosie the riveter with your own tools
this is also about making it much easier
for others including independent repair
shops to help fix your stuff
that doesn't look good
this doesn't look good at all and it's
corroded the worst part is over here oh
boy the fare repair act which was
introduced in congress in june would
require original equipment manufacturers
to make available certain documentation
diagnostic and repair information to
independent providers over 20 states
have introduced similarly worded bills
none have been enacted yet
so what does this all mean and would
this really help you the hopeless person
with a broken gadget
yes
it probably would
certainly my journey to repair two very
dead macbooks showed it could save you
both time and money
let's first talk about these two
machines this is a 13-inch 2017 macbook
pro which at the time cost hundred
dollars
the second a 2020 macbook air that cost
eleven hundred dollars
both i grabbed from my it department and
were marked as having water damage i
promise you i did not actually spill
water on these to break them so i packed
them up and went to the apple store
since they were out of warranty and i
don't have apple care plus which covers
accidental damage i walked out of the
store pretty sad
7.99 to fix the air 9.99 to fix the pro
and the genius i spoke to basically
suggested i just buy some new machines
instead
shocker then mike's tech shop an
authorized apple service provider had
even worse news it sends the laptops out
to apple to be fixed and it adds its own
labor charge
870 for the air
1170 for the pro yeah
nope
plus both of those stores said it would
take five to seven days for the repair
that's when i decided to go to a shop
that doesn't have any relationship with
apple such as rosman repair
[Music]
the owner louis rossman has been an
advocate about the right to repair
only option is to go to apple and have
this three or four thousand dollar
device fixed by them for fifteen hundred
dollars he's also got a popular youtube
channel where he often criticizes
apple's repair restrictions champions
the right to repair and shares his
opinion on various topics it's really
important to me with right to repair
that what we're asking for be very
reasonable his price quote
325 dollars for the pro but a no-go on
the air because he didn't have the parts
or information
another independent repair store in new
york very similar pricing
[Music]
so let's think about this for a second
9.99 at apple or 325 at rosman repair
i think it's pretty simple
an apple spokesman said we believe the
safest and most reliable repair is one
handled by a trained technician using
apple genuine parts and we continue to
expand apple's offerings to better meet
our customers needs
he added that apple would replace the
entire motherboard for a repair like
this which makes it more expensive but
to really understand how this
legislation wants to change things i had
to see what was happening inside these
machines
here's the first one
it's a 13-inch macbook pro
all right the big deal is that corrosion
that goes over here is right next to
where the wi-fi data line is translation
the water caused corrosion on the
motherboard and it's around components
that help with oh you know just three
little things
power wi-fi
and your screen but rosman still thought
it had a chance so let's see if this one
has a chance of working because it
doesn't look like the corrosion around
that area is too bad
you're just gonna
do this
like filing your nails that's not what
filing my nails looks like
now two things really made this repair
possible for rossman one he had the
extra parts to swap in for the broken
parts
he got them from what are called donor
boards boards from old systems was still
usable parts
two he had schematics and board views
these are basically maps of what's in
the system so he can figure out what is
what
except these documents created by the
manufacturer aren't provided to
independent repair shops
rosman and others get these documents
which are often leaked from people that
work at the company from sites on the
internet
that's part of what the right to repair
wants to change so apple doesn't give
you any of this no
i can't get access to it as a
third-party repair center and if you
become an authorized repair center you
still can't get access to any of this
stuff and was this originally an apple
document is this like something apple
put together yeah it says right on the
bottom of it it says over here notice of
proprietary property this information
contained here in is the proprietary
property of apple inc an apple
spokesperson said that the company has
an independent repair provider program
which provides access to apple genuine
parts tools training service guides
diagnostics and resources to perform a
variety of out of warranty repairs he
added that the company has found
individual chip replacements to be
unreliable which is why it replaces the
full motherboard however rosman and
others say that this apple program does
not provide schematics or board views
and many specific parts that make
repairs more affordable for consumers
after about 15 minutes of work we were
ready to see if it had been fixed
it's on
it is on
and it's charging
okay that was the macbook pro but what
about that macbook air
no
rossman didn't have access to the
boardview document for that specific
macbook air which meant
it was a no-go this one even if i did
have all the information you know it
doesn't really have the highest chance
of being repairable but when you combine
the factor that it looks like this with
the fact that i don't have all the
information i need to do my job i i'd
say screw this why don't you have the
information to do your job because i
can't find the boardview because it's
not available i have to wait for someone
at apple or one of these factories to
leak that board view and risk their job
or risk them being in prison to one of
those websites so that i can then buy it
he also said that getting the parts to
fix the air aren't available yet to him
so to recap this 13-inch macbook pro
works perfectly now i even wrote this
script on it and i've been working on it
this macbook air well my only choice is
really to go back to apple and pay them
7.99 to fix it or i can buy a completely
new macbook air for 9.99 which really
doesn't seem like a choice at all
and that's what the right to repair is
all about giving us more choices to
repair our stuff tech companies and
opponents of the legislation argue that
that choice can impact product safety
and data security and put companies
intellectual property at risk
what do you want to see the most out of
this legislation
i'd like to see it have the
teeth to be able to do the bare minimum
which is get us access to schematics to
board views and to be able to buy these
chips it's ought to be a computer
repairman and feel like the kid in high
school that was selling weed out of the
fourth stall the lunch bathroom the
future of all this now rests in the
hands of lawmakers or in this case maybe
it should be in the hands of laptop
makers who should consider
liquid proofing
but like you could tell when cats hate
their owners based on the fact that they
piss on their computers